this is Startalk this is Startalk
and I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
I'm an astrophysicist your personal
astrophysicist and I my day job is as
the director of the Hayden Planetarium
of the American Museum of Natural
History right here in New York City and
as always for Startalk
my co-host is a professional comedian
today we have with us Eugene Mirman
Eugene thanks for being back very glad
to be yeah yeah but what you've been
doing lately you um I've been touring I
have an album that came in tour an album
in yeah okay cool that's largely what
I've been doing that's what stand-up
comedians do yeah they release an album
and they tour well everybody doesn't yet
or they're like tell people about their
album sometimes I can do it on the radio
except I read this is not an album this
is like nine yet this is nine volumes it
took a few years to make it's full of a
lot of ridiculous things and meditations
sound effects 45 minutes of crying
that's one of the volumes and so people
lined up to buy this well you don't have
to line up anymore you can use the image
Oh Oh gone is that a whole spread Ian
yeah exactly
hopefully two people stood in line I
mean there's also stand-up it's a normal
album and it's not like anyway so this
edition of Startalk cosmic queries you
we've solicited questions from our fan
base and all the different social media
platforms and you're gonna read them to
me I've not seen them before and the
this what is the theme today the theme
is new discoveries and new mysteries of
the universe okay so I hope you're up on
your new mysteries I don't know if I'm
up on this we'll find out we'll find out
because I'm classically trained and so I
know yeah so I know stuff yeah but if
I'm like turning the page of the very
latest discoveries or maybe not so ya
know if that's the case okay bring it on
Nicole Brooks from patreon asks based on
the expanding knowledge of wormholes and
Tipler cylinders do you think it is
theoretically possible to travel through
the past or the future using one of the
following devices only wormholes only
Tipler cylinders or wormholes for
present / future travel and Tipler
cylinders for the past
the answer is yes it's theoretically
possible because you can show how moving
through a wormhole can put you back in
the time frame from which you left
mm-hmm you can show that but we don't
know how to make a wormhole it's not a
realistic thing yet that we it was but
theoretically once we figure out how to
make Cajuns tell us we can do it unless
having made the wormhole we then make
discoveries that tell us that we can't
right and it's been hypothesized by
Hawking among others mm-hmm that there
might be a universal law of physics that
prevents you from traveling backwards in
time because suppose you did this and
you prevented your parents from meeting
one another then they you would have
never been conceived enough to go back
in time to prevent them from meeting one
another right so this would be it's
apparent a temporal paradox yeah and
maybe the laws of physics when we get
there will tell us about this paradox
and therefore prevent it right or create
another you couldn't get another
universe yes yeah it's like at any point
where we're a a past event has changed
then a new universe spawns off that was
just a way to not have to really answer
the question right oh if that is okay
yeah it was given serious theoretical
and physical thought right behind the
New Worlds interpretation there was
invoked for quantum physics yeah back in
the 1920s the weird things were
happening and maybe all things were
happening and we were just choosing
which path through reality accounted for
what we saw so you're not convinced the
Back to the Future trilogy as possible
certainly not the Cubs winning the World
Series apparently as they should have
done this October 250 2015 all right
well all right good okay so from
Facebook a duyst
in here asks what if there is an alien
mega-structure
what would that mean for humanity so
probably this questioner is referring to
one of the the suspected exoplanets that
Kepler the telescope discovered yeah and
normally what Kepler is looking for is a
slight dip in the light of the host star
as the planet eclipses in front of it
mm-hmm so the planet will will drop it
by maybe 1% and we can measure intensity
of light accurately enough to and with
enough precision to say how big the
planet is what its orbital period is and
all the like but it has found something
that is some structure that has no
resemblance to Planet 2 it the signature
of a planet and it's been suggested
maybe they were building a one of these
Dyson spheres where if you want to way
to think about it is if you what are we
doing to get energy we're like fighting
wars right digging stuff and Grendel's
out of the ground all right that's
pretty primitive our plants eat our
sunlight did they do they that's how
they describe it but I'm not wrong so
their levels of civilization that you
can reference depending on how
sophisticated they are in obtaining
energy so one of them would be you can
tap energy from Earth so volcanoes
earthquakes tornadoes cyclones we should
talk charging our phones with tornadoes
exactly if you can do that then earth is
supplying all the energy you need or
it's a source of energy unlike anything
you might have had before well can you
go more than that yes you could tap all
the energy that your host star can give
you well how would you do that well you
can put up solar panels whether you can
only put that on the surface of the
earth but it's sending energy out in
every direction in space mm-hmm so why
not put up solar panels all around the
star so all the energy that leaves the
star hits the solar panels and you take
every ounce of energy that star has to
give you that's another level of so and
then how do you get that to your planet
well you wire it up or whatever I mean
you'd have a very long cable yes if you
can do that you might have a sub salute
exactly exactly you figure that out and
the next level of civilization is you
command all the energy of all the stars
in your galaxy and the highest level
would be commanding all the energy of
all the galaxies in the universe
so we would have to be a higher level
civilization to be able to maneuver and
manipulate wormholes and so we're not
there yet we are so far from it yeah so
so there you have it okay yeah yeah
what's next next is James from Facebook
he asks what is New Horizons mission now
or is it just drifting towards the
kookier Belt yeah so the New Horizons
mission that's the mission that went to
find Pluto and did a flyby got awesome
data from Pluto closeup high-resolution
images that are still coming in the
spacecraft was pared down and wait so
that it could get to its destination as
fast as possible because the number one
rule in science is what go very quickly
you want to finish your experiment
before you die right so going quickly
would matter yeah so you have the lucky
not totally wrong you're not totally
wrong so you want the lightest
spacecraft and the most powerful
boosters mm-hmm to get you there and
that's a potent combination for getting
there quickly so we got to Pluto in in
10 years yeah and and we passed the
moon's orbit in 9 hours we I mean the
spacecraft yeah and 900 it took the it
took the astronauts three days to cover
that distance so this thing's booking
out of the solar system so it past Pluto
in a flyby and now it is not adrift in
the Kuiper belt they're selecting
targets for it
it still has fuel so it can maneuver in
in certain by certain angle and that
angle is enough to have it come close to
other frozen bodies in the outer solar
system whose properties resemble that of
the moon and it's sending that info back
to us as well it will one way it gets
there that's correct
yeah okay great all right Jared on
Facebook asses to build megastructures
in space when you need something say the
size of a mineral-rich asteroid belt or
a moon mind for the same so what they're
saying is if you're gonna build a huge
structure in space that uses more
mineral resources than your planet can't
supply yeah you'd have to get this stuff
in from space yeah but that's not a
problem because we know the asteroids
are an unlimited Sencha ly limitless
supply yeah of all the ingredients that
would otherwise be rare on earth so the
rare earth elements there's only rare on
earth right they're not rare an asteroid
in particular handpicked asteroids so
yeah you would need resources from
beyond your home planet but with people
are well aware of that yeah and I think
if you're building this mega structure
you'd that's what you direct that's how
I would do it yeah Dave Maass
Facebook asks what needs to be improved
in carbon nanotube technology to build
large space structures but so I so first
of all the some years ago I forgot what
year it was was it 1989 or 90 when they
discovered a new molecule carbon 60
mm-hmm this is 60 carbon atoms that the
way to make 60 carbon atoms into one
molecule is you can connect them in a
particular way where they end up making
a sphere and that sphere was the the
vertices of the geodesic dome mm-hmm
that was advanced by Buckminster Fuller
and so these these spheres came to be
known as bucky balls and i think they
are the same seams and nodes that you
find on a stiched soccer ball the older
soccer ball that has X a Gon's and and
Pentagon's so so there it is now if you
cut it in the middle and spread it and
then put carbon fibers connecting one
side to another you go from a carbon
Bucky ball to a carbon nanotube so it's
the same scale of chemistry and so this
would be way stronger than steel way
lighter than steel it would completely
transform construct the construction
industry because you want things that
are strong but light yes it's kind of
how that works
sounds like transparent aluminum from
Star Trek that's the save the whales
yeah exactly so question now is if you
can build long tubes these would replace
steel cables for all of your needs and
make things lighter cheaper faster
better
the problem is last I checked the
longest nano tube that they've been able
to make has been maybe a centimeter down
and because we don't have tools to plant
to position molecules we have to coax
them into these configurations based on
the apparatus and the temperature and
the pressure and and the mixture of
other chemical once they're made they
can they live out in the world yeah I
don't see why not
given our strengths and so so once now
the the space elevator will you take an
elevator to orbit is something that
would basically require carbon nanotubes
but we have
go from a centimeter length to 23,000
miles of length right this is we're not
there yet
yeah that sounds yeah it sounds like
it's gonna take time
right okay Martin Holden asks on
Facebook what are the books that a
budding cosmologists should have in
their library it depends on what level
but I would say a fun book just cuz it's
big an audacious big hairy and audacious
is a book called gravitation mm-hmm and
it's written by three authors Misner
thorne and wheeler wheeler was the guy
who first coined the term black hole
Thorne was the guy who was the science
advisor to the movie interstellar mm-hm
and his first name is Kip and one of the
robots in interstellar was called Kip by
the way in case you're no longer with us
yes as Bill Nye is fond of saying and
also he wrote a companion book to the
movie interstellar called the science of
interstellar so he's one of the authors
and the third is it as a professor from
the University of Maryland and Charles
Misner and that it's a huge book is
called just called gravitation and
they're two tracks the WIMP track and
the advanced track in the book in the
book or layman the other color-coded and
so if you want the easier track you read
the pages with the black corners and you
want the harder when you read the ones
with the white corners
oh yeah maybe I'll try it so that one if
you're if you're kind of advanced yeah
the one I read you either one but if not
then there's so many excellent popular
level books Brian Greene's the fabric of
the cosmos and and Lisa Randall has
three books all about cosmology and our
understanding of our place in the
universe so you can start with those
popular level accounts and then ascend
from there okay yeah um Amy danger on
face book a straight name I know a very
good name my nine-year-old daughter
wants to know why our moon doesn't have
a name I'm with her why doesn't remove
it does have a name what it Jeff
Freddie yeah so I stir me so all the
planets are named for Latin gods so you
would expect any name for Earth or the
moon to be Latin and so you you would
expect it would expect so the Earth Moon
and Sun
have Latin corresponding names and we
can use the use them in my field
everyone know what your what's the name
of the name of Earth is Terra Terra the
name of the moon is Luna Luna oh yeah
yeah and the name of the Sun is Sol oh
not like it's so you L yeah it really
cool but Sol and so those Latin words
have all been lifted to become the roots
of other words
Sol Sol is the the root of solar system
right and Luna like lunatic and lunar
month and yeah this sort of thing so was
a lunatic is someone who acts crazy
after they see the full moon but they
don't tend to act crazy when it's cloudy
out right they don't even know that it's
full I didn't know that lunatics
specifically with someone who was crazy
for moonlight Oh your moonlight we call
it well no one uses it that way no
that's not that is okay yeah wow that's
great to know so Amy the moon does have
a name is Luna
yes Sol Sol Terra and Luna nice Martin
Holden asks on Facebook is space
continuous or granular all evidence
points to that it's granular in a
quantum physics which has been trumping
every other field that it has touched
mm-hmm it's the most accurate theory of
the universe we have ever put forth
tells us that space is granular that
there's a so what does it mean for it to
because you smallest possible lengths
that you can measure in space there's a
smallest possible unit of time that can
exist in space and this granulation of
space and time would tell us that in
fact space is not continuous by the way
general relativity Einstein's theory of
gravity requires that space be smoothly
continuous so there's a there's a
shotgun war going on there about who's
gonna be right in the end and if you're
a betting person you put your money on
quantum physics really wait so that
means that if you were to get to the
edge of the universe then what would be
nothing about the edge of how small you
can divide the fabric of space and time
oh by the way this is not a weird
concept right if you take a sheet and
you say okay give me a section of the
she'd and you cut it section are fine
and I give you a 1 foot square let's say
and now you send on a smaller section I
give you 1 inch square I want an even
smaller section 1 millimeter squared now
suppose you're asking me for a section
of the squeak the sheet that is smaller
then the fibers are tracking within the
sheet mm-hmm is that still sheet ooh
yeah your fibers are there now you're in
a zone within the stitches of the fiber
where there's no sheet at all so pieces
of the sheet are no longer heterogeneous
ly represented right because your sizing
is smaller than the stuff dropping it in
the first place so now you're going to
that's building blocks this way exactly
so so right now everything looks
continuous because we're not we're not
dealing with these very small sizes
right but when you do get there and you
try to measure time you'll find that you
won't be able to and its granular yes
all right
now I understand I just learned recently
there's a freak me out and I have to
like read up on it cuz it's not where so
I learned that some ideas of the
expanding universe will have the
universe in some places where the
space-time fabric itself melts what does
that mean I don't know what it means I
tried to I'll come back to you on this
okay because I'm very curious like
that's what it means for space-time to
melt right that the space-time might
have corresponding states of matter
going on within them and and you might
be able to melt space and I just and
then you could you could drink it I
can't wait to tell people I've drunk one
liter of molten space I don't know I
hope we all find out in 2038
we'll come back to cosmic queries
wondering what are the new discoveries
in the universe stay with us
back on Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson Eugene Mirman right here
Eugene what do you what do you tweet it
at Eugene Mirman knew that yeah I know I
just wanna get you to say that yeah no
you you tricked me now it's like Mick
selects I you've said said my name
forwards and I'm still here
so it's great fall I do follow you and
it's great just hearing your your
reflection sometimes is he serious or is
he something wonder you know what maybe
I mean both maybe comedians need more
emoticons to sound they're just so we
know we're on our journey and there's
another one who died see joke about this
they say back in my day we had to use
our face to make emoticons so so you've
got questions from our fan base yeah and
it's just about new discoveries in the
universe and if I don't know it I just I
don't know Oh answer it anyway some
misleading okay here we go
William on Twitter asks what are your
thoughts on the mysterious structure
orbiting a star 1500 light-years away
yes so that's related to the earlier
question about alien megastructures yeah
so I I don't know what that structure is
by the way I didn't I don't think I
detailed earlier these structures that
pass between the telescope and the host
star it's we know it's not a planet so
so so what what are some of the options
and what it's giving the light in odd
significant and unusual ways right of
the host that we've never seen before
never seen I've never seen and that's
why people think of they're building
structures to grab the sunlight the star
light and beam it back to the home
planet so so I tend to be very
conservative in my yeah in my scientists
alien civilization the subject of
advanced alien civilization and I would
say just because we do not know what it
is it does not then mean it's alien
mega-structure right something we don't
know it's so and I said it's probably
something more mundane accounting for it
like a super thick cloud of space debris
odd I don't know what is the water
what kinds of so alien mega-structure is
one theory and after that one hypothesis
sorry right yeah yeah so what are some
other hypotheses because there's the
theory of evolution in Syria gravity
right and and the hypothesis yeah yeah
it's not you G's theory is once it's
been agreed on it yeah yeah it's very
powerful and okay i bothers is is like
this is a very good guess and you just
came up with it on the spot yeah so what
are some other hypotheses so alien Megan
maybe a cloud of comets that had broken
apart but we're still traveling together
as a game really good get some mind yeah
a huge comment and you break it apart
into multiple pieces all the pieces
still travel together Oh in orbit around
the Sun kind of like Anna o in a pack of
cards like an a bunch of yeah yeah burn
they'll slowly separate flocking yeah
they'll slowly separate but not until
you get some good right movements there
so if you have to start with a huge
comet and it breaks apart into a hundred
pieces now you have more blockage of
your hosts are but it still was not
repeating periodically which any
orbiting object would do so it's a it's
a tremendously fascinating mystery and
I'm content in knowing it's a mystery
not all the choir of the mystery that it
yields a solution on the spot John on
Twitter asks as the universe expands
well the Higgs field expand and thus
weakened to the point of matter
degeneration
same with EMF yeah so I don't know if
what effect the expansion of the
universe has on the Higgs field mm-hmm
I'm guessing it might dilute it in some
way and the question is how does that
then affect the mass that it grants to
particles within that field so I I do
not know the answer to that okay Joey
make up an answer no I appreciate your
honesty more okay sorry wrong answer on
my part if make up an answer if it did
weaken and that somehow interfered with
the ability of the Higgs field to grant
master particles mm-hmm that would be
completely destabilizing on the universe
mm-hmm that'd be awesome and what would
happen then well I don't know if
particles have less mass than we thought
they did or they can I fly could I be
able to fly
and just because you'd have less mass
doesn't mean you can fly know how so it
but what it would there be a point at
which though that would be the case you
need strength in another thing okay or
because Roper Mac body weight what if I
could control magnets well then you're
not like like Megan oh yeah but then
you're not really no I say I mean yeah
you you're you need maggots magnets
wherever you need to do your you're
trying yeah right right okay fair enough
I just trying to figure out how I could
fly but I don't think that's what he was
trying to do okay David asks on Twitter
will the presence of water on Mars
affect how we manufacture fuel for the
return trip not for the well in the
future possible certainly yeah yeah
because fuel the what is water made of
the chemically h2o thing very nice very
nice and h2o it turns out is rocket fuel
not in the form of order but if you
separate the hydrogen and the oxygen and
you bring them together to make a
molecule the water molecule then they it
is hugely exothermic mm-hmm a lot of
energy gets released and it makes an
ideal rocket fuel so if you go to Mars
and you want to use resources in situ
mmm-hmm then converting the water under
the soils into rocket fuel is an ideal
usage usage case so the future of that
expedition okay so yeah James asked what
question would you like to have answered
before you die regardless of if you
think it will or even can be and why
yeah so I've got a cop-out answer to
that uh-huh I like the questions that no
one have thought up yet have thought of
yet because they only emerge from having
made a discovery that you're after in
that moment right those are the
questions I so so I would not have even
known to ask 100 years ago
how many asteroids could render humans
on earth extinct because the asteroids
were not thought not known to cross the
orbit of the earth so so now I'm asking
a question that was unforeseen Bo right
in a day so this would be something like
how do we control wormholes to go back
in time to kill all our grandparents
but we can't conceive of that quite yet
yeah so so so this is the this is the
challenge I would say mm-hmm the
challenge is that coming up with is new
discoveries that will lead to new
questions yeah so yeah sorry so so so I
think this is my challenge in coming up
with the question because I love the
questions that have not even been
thought up yet so therefore I can't even
share them with you right but when they
do arise it's like wow that was good
that was a good one right yeah all right
Louis asks theoretically
if a man is sent to Mars for a year
would he be awake and asleep for the
same amount of time as a earthling yeah
I mean you can set a schedule that's
slightly different from Earth maybe a 20
maybe a 25 hour day or a 23 hour day and
people that tend to stay up later in the
morning people and their nighttime
people yeah you could probably take a
boatload of nighttime people put them on
a ship and have them go to Mars and have
them live in a 26 or 27 maybe even a
twenty eight hour day because they're
always staying up late pushing how
what's the day of Mars how long is it
that's about 24 hours okay
oh that's very cool you wouldn't even
need to know yeah it may be different by
20 minutes or something okay but by the
way people who work on Mars or rather
scientists colleagues of mine who study
Rovers that were at work on Mars they
have a watch that's made so that the 24
hours on that watch matches the exact
rotation rate of Mars so that they can
live on a Mars time as well as human
time right and I wonder if they go like
okay well see you at dinner at 7 Mars
time and the reason where they have to
do that is they need to know when Moke
many of the Rovers have solar panels in
things and all of them have solar panels
and so you need to know when is it
exposed to the Sun recharging its
batteries when is it not right good
answer mm-hmm all right jared has a
question and his question is would it be
plausible to find gravity waves
by observing the resonant frequency of
say a mile-long piano string ooh hmm
what do you think yeah so the mass and
energy in a piano string is insufficient
to generate a detectable gravity wave so
you need you need a major gravitational
disturbance in the fabric of space and
time what would that into a collision of
two black holes Oh collision of two
piano strings not measuring up to the -
yeah sorry about that but but he's
thinking that that this vibration would
somehow vibrate the fabric of the
universe and know it would vibrate any
kind of air molecules right that it
touched on doing so and in space there's
no air module so it'll just swing back
and forth but it won't generate sound
right because the vibration of the air
molecules is what we sense a sound the
saddest thing is a piano in space all
right any musical instrument in space no
just pianos the trumpet well yeah just
feels like well because of the cost to
put a piano there Dennard on Google+
asks with slowing investments in
space-based science across the board in
multiple countries what effect does this
have on limiting human discoveries of
our place in the universe yeah that's
that's a great question and if you're
gonna cut back on science which is the
current which would constitute the
current roads of discovery then just
move back into the cave yeah what are
you doing now you can vote for that kind
of country but that's not the kind of
country I grew up in right
we had investments in science and
technology you did not need special
programs to convince kids that they
should be interested in science doesn't
built into the fabric of the media
cycles well NASA for every dollar put
into NASA returns something like seven
or eight dollars yeah I hardly ever cite
that calculation because there's a lot
of or is it somewhat accurate but it's a
matter of what you value that goes into
the equation that gets that number so
that that's the kind of same calculation
you do when you say well let's put an
opera in town yeah well how are we going
to support the Opera well we don't know
but if you
an opera there then these stores will
open up around the entrance to that
operate and so it's a seating effect
right right many people talk about but
but it's it's hard to actually say it's
hard to anchor that in a way that if
five different people did the same
analysis would they get the same answer
and the answer is no and that also isn't
necessarily the scientific discovery is
partially its own end not the fact that
correct yeah correct
even though some people want you to do
it for some purpose it's really for its
own in and later on you find out how it
really applies yeah all right George
organ Jurgen Nyberg asks he was writing
from the west coast of Sweden on organ
yeah your organ your iceberg mhm
any news Rek I see eight four six two
eight five two if not do you know what
the period dasa T of the dimming has
been yes so this is again that this is
more alien when he's like wait as you
read that you sound like a second grader
reading yeah I mean well this I also you
know without knowing the the actual
number of the planet or whatever it
sounds like maybe it's also a failed
death threat like any news rate like is
like oh don't get cold yes exactly what
do you know about yeah yeah so no any
word I'm asking on the radio no there's
no no updates and it's it's got people
it's got people thinking long and hard
and deep about what it could be but for
me like I said I don't know what it is
and I reserve comment okay yeah we have
one last question okay
mark millar patreon he asks so patreon
is that's our funding it's a it's a it's
you can be a funding friend
yeah of Startalk yeah where and you get
certain perks
yeah like we'll bring your question to
the top of the list
I had asked one patreon question and we
have one more one more
yeah you'll just get to the list well
mark already got to ask one in another
episode so marks getting a real ton of
question in there yeah but they're
depending on your participation level
yeah promote the the innovations that
we're trying to
bring - yeah for $1,000,000 I'll carry
you nine feet okay that's just one thing
I love I think we can do better than
that
Eugene well if you really love Startalk
so don't we had to do better than that
very happy our patreon supporters so
thanks for being out there yes folks so
go ahead go ahead
let me ask marks question with the
discovery of a black hole expelling some
of the matter it had consumed what
forces may be responsible for this
unusual behavior oh it's not unusual
because it's not coming from within the
event horizon once you cross over the
event horizon just you know kiss your
ass good-bye
so what's actually happening is all this
matter is spiraling towards the black
hole Center and it can't all get there
all at once and it forms this disk on
which all this material accretes and the
disk feeds the black hole on the very
inner edge of it but until you until it
gets to that point you still have this
this this assembly of matter and as it
spirals down and gets hotter and hotter
and hotter and it begins to radiate the
radius so ferociously it punches out
above and below the disk itself and then
you get these Jets these these these
long spewed forth signatures of moving
matter and so so yes
this happens because all this matters
trying to get down into the same place
at the same time and it's gonna fail in
doing so and once you heat up a gas it's
got to radiate somewhere and it'll do it
it'll do it yeah oh it will that's the
promise I make to you so yeah so most of
the exotic galactic center phenomenon
we've seen with powerful Jets emanating
from above and below our galaxy and very
intense in all bands of light radio
waves microwaves ultraviolet x-rays so
we have we have established over the
decades that the thing that's causing
all that violence in the galaxies are
black holes with matter trying to get in
there too fast
creating these explosive accretion discs
so that's how it comes out of a black
hole and we're we say it loosely oh this
came out of the black hole no it came
out of the vicinity of the black hole
not out of the black hole itself but
when we come back more cosmic queries on
the latest stuff in the universe I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson Eugene Mirman we'll
see you in a moment
we're back on Startalk cosmic queries
edition first two segments we did
questions related to news discoveries
exactly and now we're going straight to
grab bag' alright let's see what it is
let's do this Andrew asks is it possible
that the long-term collection of matter
space mining may cause a change in the
way the Earth orbits the Sun or the moon
orbits the earth is there a tipping
point of the earth collecting changing
mass from a large asteroid that can
change its gravitational pull on the
moon or the sun's pull on the earth yes
yeah next question no it's not as bad as
you think
however because if you take all of the
asteroids in the asteroid belt mm-hmm
and collected it together back into one
solid mass mm-hmm you can ask how much
is that Florida okay so it's about 5% of
the mass of our Moon mm-hmm so one
twentieth of the moon and so we could
accumulate all mass of all the asteroids
and we would barely notice it in terms
of our own weight mm-hmm and the moon's
orbit would adjust a little but not by
not much right and so it's really not
not an issue okay yeah nothing to loosen
the belt scared of that and by the way
anything large enough that we did bring
to earth that would badly disrupt our
orbit would be bad enough on earth to
render us extinct so it would not be the
kind of questioning like Mars if we
brought Mars to earth that would be bad
very bad yes that's the end of both Mars
and Earth what's the most with Mars
without it being a problem you can put
it wherever you want but and it'll
affect our orbit around the Sun but not
in any bad way but you want to combine
them yeah that's bad super plan super
that's bad for both okay right Adrian
asks hello dr. Tyson would it be
possible within our lifetime to extend
people's natural life synthetically
through either BIOS cybernetics or
bioengineering to such an extent that
while they may not live forever they
might certainly be around for the next
100 to 200 years or more yeah so I we
got people working on this now this is
this is not science fiction it's science
fact
and and it people are thinking oh the
engineering of it we hybridize biology
with with material science and perhaps
and maybe that's not even necessary
maybe we just find the gene for aging
and snip it cut it alter it what would
happen so how would a geing work if
theoretically you didn't age the way
that things currently age because you'd
still get older like you'd still have
things you would be older yeah but to
get older we make synonymous with
becoming more frail or weak right you
would be an older entity yes right so
there would be a different a new type of
frailty would develop we're just from
simply being 200 years old you might
have a frailty that you didn't have is
that what you're saying no I'm saying if
you if you live if you live a long time
beyond any current actuarial tables it
may be that the decline we see in our
bodies from age like 50 to 80 maybe that
would happen between age a hundred and
100 and between 150 and 200 for example
right but you have a more a bigger chunk
of your time being alive would you would
be physically fit and help right you can
play a lot more soccer it has huge
consequences because that means the
population of the earth could would go
up yeah and let the human population
unless you made fewer babies because the
equilibrium of people and new jobs and
all it has built in the fact that people
die well what if we just let only rich
people live forever would that be
something people would like well that's
what happened in what's the movie time
the time was a come on oh yeah then
there's where there's money where like
they built the space station
no but there's a lot of movies where the
rich people get to live for a long time
all right well that's good to know that
people are working on this terrible
thing that will destroy mankind but also
be kind of fun I think it to live
forever I've spoken on this before I
I think that's misguided it's suppose
you actually live forever right then
what is the value of tomorrow
to you well maybe if you just live for
200 years then you still have like a
little fear but not as much about it
yeah I just wonder
I knowing that I'm going to die yeah is
a fundamental part of what creates
meaning for any moment I'm alive right
and if a day goes by where I didn't like
discover something or learn something or
or play with my kids or going to play
date with my wife or or or contribute to
this world in some fundamental way I
wasted that day and if I live forever I
would not have the state of mind that I
could waste any time at all right and I
don't know what that would mean for
people's creativity you could still be
blown up in a war if that makes you feel
any better you mean did not die
naturally right right right yeah
so I think it living forever might be
overrated yeah the living for 200 years
underrated all right Aaron asks how are
those fashionable easily worn space
suits coming along read the Mars episode
of Nova ScienceNOW
yeah so I don't have the latest on that
but they you know part of the challenge
of course is the spacesuit needs to be
pressurized because typically you're
bounding around in someplace that
doesn't have normal atmospheric pressure
and it's got to keep you your
temperature regulated mm-hmm warm when
it's cold out and cool when it's warm
out and that can change on a dime yep
ending up what side of you is facing the
Sun for example and so and you want it
to be flexible so you can still bound
around a planetary surface and maybe do
science experiments or or just do sports
right right it's true maybe you want to
play space tennis okay or something and
when you do that you want to have the
mobility that a that a flexible space
suit would give you a nice I don't know
the latest on that and I should check up
on that okay by the way if anyone is
gonna spend meaningful time on Mars I'm
thinking they're gonna want one of these
space suits for sure cuz they're one
you're gonna want to do Mars Taichi
exactly dude Martin cooking classes
yes exactly okay Tyler wants to know
would have somewhat self-sustaining moon
base drastically improve the likelihood
of a manned Mars mission yes however I
think so however I don't know what it
means to be a self-sustaining moon base
because we're you're getting your food
well you probably you bring a cow and
you'd eat just a little bit of the cow
you keep it
live like in that horrifying movie the
road
so yeah you we would give us a lot of
training just to moving stuff into
another location pitching tent right and
but we shouldn't think of that as a
stepping stone to Mars is way better
just go straight to Mars it right
explore space but just I happen to like
the moon as a target for this because
it's within a media cycle away it's like
three days away right right when you
launch from Earth so you can check up on
the astronauts how are you doing you
could build like a sort of French
Quarter like in New Orleans but you
could put it on the moon and you could
have some jazz yeah to make it it'll be
a place at outpost
yeah human outpost so I think we do be a
lot of training for what it is to do
that mm-hmm what kind of supply chain of
food you would need and other resources
and do you send up a doctor who can then
you know surgeon you know we get to
think about how to make that happen
how if you had no training and you went
into space how sick like would you die
or would you just be very upset but what
would be weird is if you have a group of
people that go to space and then virus
mutates and then it affects just that
group of people because you're all
breathing the same air right eating the
same food and touching each other's
bodies and so so then you have some
weird virus that you didn't have vaccine
against because it just arose in that
moment and so that so maybe this is the
kind of thing you you need confidence
that you have way better control over
the spread of viruses under those
situations than what anybody is
exhibiting today okay yeah yeah okay so
here's a question rambling Scott asks oh
never mind yes
how much can you been what you ask me
okay
rambling Scott wants to know how much
can you bet how much can I bet so he
didn't ask me on what planetary surface
no but I think it's implied that it's
Venus
okay so Venus has approximately the same
gravity as does Earth and so I'd be
benching about the same Mars however if
you saw the Martian there's
the obligatory image of Matt Damon with
his chest sticking out and his six-pack
abs he's every movie I think has to have
a guy with six-pack ABS yeah so that we
can completely delude the entire
heterosexual female population into
thinking that this is just a common
thing on guys
right yes people talk a lot about how
men are subjected to these terrible
standards it's so exhausting for us
can't live up to those standards yeah so
and where have they heard that before
right yeah so so on so he's buff yeah
but and there he is you see him lifting
these huge canisters up and down the
stomach area basin of the rover and you
say well he's buff so that's why he's
doing it no he was doing it because he's
on Mars right and if it weighs 300
pounds on earth
it weighs 120 pounds on Mars and I want
to get up and put it put it where he
wants so they did this in the movie they
understood this yeah and so yes it does
help to be strong but he doesn't have to
be as strong as you thought he was right
so and that would be a fun so then
boxing would be or like Ultimate
Fighting would be much more fun to watch
on Mars cuz everybody so powerful but I
don't know you're not more powerful you
doesn't have any more punch to it you
could just lift a bigger thing with RO a
bigger person yes you could throw people
yeah okay it would be fun to watch a
throwing contest
judo match exactly yeah you can flip
people all over so so I would I would
bench on Mars so so what'd you take how
much I bench on earth divided by 0.4
mm-hmm and then you get a bigger number
when you're done and that's how much
more I can bench okay a bench on Mars
but you notice I didn't say how much I
can actually bench I'm sure on Mars it's
between three and seven hundred actually
that's a very very good yeah let's go to
a lightning round yeah okay okay okay
let's do okay Higgs wants to know how
fast is the speed of dark if Dark Matter
emitted light would it be the same speed
everything that is electromagnetic
energy goes at exactly the same speed so
if your Dark Matter emitted any kind of
light which we know it doesn't but if it
did and
at any kind of species association with
light at all even if it's a new band of
light because the light we know and love
microwaves radio waves gamma rays these
all bands of light all travels at speed
of light so do gravity waves for example
so if it's gonna send out energy through
space we're pretty sure it's gonna be
moving at the speed of light right okay
okay
go what and why does it go uh what and
why does it glow at the center of
galaxies the center of galaxies most any
time we've had enough data to look in
the center of a galaxy with precision we
find a supermassive black hole flying
and dining upon stars that come too
close and in the act of doing so they
become highly radiant just outside of
their event horizon okay and so yeah so
watch every center of every galaxy
including our own okay we're all
watching good do have you watch out for
it yeah yeah do heavier elements get
produced in black holes like a star with
nuclear fusion
if heavy elements get produced in the
centers of black holes I didn't know
maybe because matter is so dense and
under we know what matter does under
very dense situations and what is that
in your opinion you can emerge nuclei
and make heavier elements this is what
goes on in the Centers of stars so I do
not know what the matter is doing at the
center of the black hole after it has
passed through okay III I do not know
yeah okay
when will New Horizons overtake the two
Voyager spacecraft as the farthest
man-made object from Earth so it turns
out turns out the Voyager and I did I
ran the numbers on this Voyager one
which is the farthest spacecraft from
Earth will actually never be overtaken
by by New Horizons the New Horizons
mission mission to Pluto because the
Voyager missions got gravity boosts upon
going out and moving past Saturn mmm at
past Jupiter got a huge gravity boost
and at that point it had more energy to
leave the solar system than the New
Horizons mission ever did and so the New
Horizons mission we wanted to there to
get quickly so we didn't have time to
chase planets T to to borrow some of
their orbital energy to speed
not borrow take their order but energy
to speed up they went Spacek Elise trait
to Pluto but if you're not going
straight you can meander and as you may
ender then you can steal orbital energy
from planets and go out real fast it'll
never overtake it Voyager is the is the
crown winner of that contest for now boy
we got it we got it we got it wow that
was quick
it was good oh my god we did the
lightning round you've been listening to
star talk radio and I've been your host
Neil deGrasse Tyson and that's been my
co-host Eugene Mirman Eugene thanks as
always for doing this thank you very
much for having me Neil and as always
from his desk I bid you to keep looking
up this is Startalk
[Music]